why does everyone ask to come and feel
it I got done a huge deal
I got the election
I got ATM
I got plenty on my plate he's on the
floor tom explain me what he's doing
he's losing terrifyingly nosy it's like
if Santa Claus was a hit man
we were cut out behind our backs
but there's a shape for things for us
we partner up with Sandy and Stewie with
Pierce
death wrestling ogres
excited to get into this knife fight
let's blow it up
I'm not authorized to let you take off
it's Dad you know and in Buddhism
sometimes your greatest Tormentor can
also be your most perceptive teacher hey
Buddha nice Tom Ford
it was a night of the Long Knives coming
I need a fire breather your help with
maths you really want me I need you
Mr Menken my most unworthy opponent
still clinging to your slice of pie
what are you at now one person the fear
is it could get squeezed
squeeze down from one because that's the
lowest number
I love you
but you are not serious people I have it
on good authority there is a kill list
is your head on straight
we've been schooled by a barbarian that
goes by the name Logan Roy I mean he's
out of control
you want to clear the air you're a snake
you have hurt me more than you can
possibly imagine I have some concerns
about your old man
I will sue and I will go public you
point your finger at me I point my
finger at you we are going to grind you
down man we are sanding the gears I hate
you do you understand that loud and
clear good done
I'm gonna build something bigger faster
Wilder
Ness
we are pirates
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign